MANO MARKS: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming
to our session.
My name is Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate at
Google and we have Chad
Killingsworth here from
Missouri State University.
We're gonna be presenting
on map once map anywhere.
I'm gonna be talking to you
today about how to create cross
functional, cross platform
maps using the Google
Maps API version 3.
Now some of it's going to be a
broad overview of different
options and then I'm gonna
drill into some specific code
and I'll talk to you a little
bit more about the specifics of
what I'm going to go
into in a minute.
I just wanted to give you that
notion so that if you're
session shopping right now you
have the option of moving
on to something else.
Map once, map anywhere,
developing geospacial
applications for both
desktop and mobile.
I will commit, at this point,
to that being the last time I
actually read directly
off the slide.
What do we mean by write
once, run everywhere?
This is an obvious take off on
one of these slogans that often
goes around the web or around
computer science where you talk
about applications that will
run on any type of platform.
The farthest back that I can
remember it was Java; I'm sure
it goes back before that.
The idea then was that you
could write an application that
would run on MACS or PC's or
anything using the
JAVA run time.
In this case what I'm going to
be talking about specifically
is different kinds of devices
back that can implement the
Google Maps API verison 3.
Particularly looking at desktop
and laptop implementations
verses mobile implementations
and getting a sense of the
different classes of devices
that we're talking about.
The question is why are
we talking about this?
For most people who live in the
United States, this is your
primary method of accessing the
web, a laptop or a
desktop computer.
For most people who live
outside, one of these devices
is the primary method
of accessing the web.
Google looked at this problem
a little over a year ago and
decided, for the foreseeable
future, mobile would be hot
and desktop would be hot.
These are two platforms that we
needed to support and so we
came up with, for the Goggle
Maps API, we came up with one
API that would work well on
both of these platforms.
In doing so we wanted to save
you development time; we wanted
you to be able to create one
map that would work in multiple
places and you wouldn't
have to recreate that map.
We also wanted to give
you faster development
turnaround time.
We were looking around at our
Google Maps API, which is on
Android, and the Google Maps
API, which is on the iPhone,
which is an Apple API and we
were thinking about that and
thinking about the fact that if
you need to fix a bug or you
need to release a new map,
you'd have to release
a new application.
We wanted to save
that pain for you.
We wanted to give you the
most featured API, the
most featured mapping API
that we could provide.
One map to rule
them all, kind of.
We're doing this on all the geo
talks, at least today, just to
give you a little sense of
which API's we're
talking about.
I'm gonna look over to
this monitor to my left.
We're looking primarily at the
JavaScript API version 3.
I'm also going to talk about
the Static Maps API and some of
these web services that are
available within there.
I'm going to look a little bit
at AJAX Search API as well and
many of these things are
related to the entire topic.
This is a general overview, so
as I said, I'm going to do
this overview of the geo
API's, which I just did.
I'm gonna talk about the
different options for mobile
development and then I'm gonna
talk about different user
interface considerations that
you might need to think about
for mobile devices compared
to laptops or desktops.
I'm going to talk about geo
location, particularly looking
at HTML five geo location but
looking at some of the options
that are available in HTML
five that Google provides.
Chad is going to talk about his
experience developing a real
world mobile application using
the Google Maps API version 3.
So just a quick note,
there's a wave up.
There are live notes being
taken; there's somebody out
there in the audience taking
notes on my session.
I don't know you who you are.
If you have any questions feel
free to post them in there.
At the end of the session we'll
pull that up on the screen and
also you can ask questions
using the microphones.
Now if you want, I'm gonna
actually put, on most of the
slides, at the bottom, you'll
see the url there, so that'll
be on most of the slides so
that you don't have to quickly
log into Wave right now.
But if a question comes up
that'll be available to you.
So I wanted to give you an
overview of some options for
doing Google Maps on a mobile
device and I talked to you
specifically about Maps on
mobile because I think
the other ones are
fairly well known.
Some of this may be familiar
to some of you from
previous presentations.
I'm not going to spend too much
time on any one of these
options but I just wanted
to go through them.
The one that we like the best,
because as you will hear over
and over again from Google, is
Google's betting on the Web.
We believe in the Web.
We believe in browsers
on mobile devices.
In mobile devices particularly;
in Android and iPhone devices
and we hope to expand this to a
larger class of mobile devices
that will start using Web Kit,
particularly, or any full
JavaScript support.
We support using directly in a
browser based application,
having people navigate directly
to a particular page.
We recognize that's not the
only option that's out there
and that there might be some
other considerations and I'll
talk about some of the other
reasons for using other things.
There's also the iPhone native
API so within the iPhone SDK
there's map kit There's the
Android native map view
and related APIs.
There's also an option to do
a hybrid native application
which embeds a browser in it.
So it takes advantage of both
the best and worst of both
worlds which is you write
applications for individual
platforms but you embed a
browser within it and load the
Google Maps API version 3.
Finally, there's the Static
Maps API which is essentially
an image server.
First I want to
do a comparison.
You can see here the major
features of the different
Goggle Maps API's on the
different platforms.
The first column is, of course,
the Maps API version 3.
We've made a lot of strides in
the last year to get a lot of
extra features and of course,
we'll continue to
iterate on those.
Then you can see the iPhone and
Android columns as well which
do provide you with some
additional features.
Everybody has the basic
functionality of
giving you a map.
Everybody has a basic
functionality to give you some
makers to put on that map.
All but the Google Maps
on the iPhone give you
direct geo coding access.
The iPhone gives you reverse
geo coding which all but
Static Maps API gives you.
You have to look and see which
API supports which thing.
I have a little asterisk there
by the polygons and polylines.
Because both Android and
iPhone, prior to version 4.0,
provide a way to do overlays
but not ones that specifically
make it easy to make
polygons and polylines.
That's why there's
that asterisk there.
I do note that in the iPhone in
the 4.0 SDK, which was recently
released, that you can create
polylines and polygons.
There's quite a few services
that are available within the
maps API version 3 that are not
available in the rest of them.
And of course there's
street view.
Those of you who have been to
some of the earlier talks today
in Daniel Lee's talk ealier.
He talked about our new release
of street view which is
available now in the
mass API version 3.
There are also native APIs
in the iPhone and Android's
platforms as well.
There is no street view
in the Static Maps API.
Just to be clear, when you
think about street view you
probably think about flash
because in version 2, the
street view allowed you
to embed a flash player.
But now with the new street
view API, we support HTML 5
canvas 2 D, which is one of our
preferred rendering platforms,
if the browser supports it.
We basically detect what
the browser will support
and then render there.
We support HTML 4 which is
what is generally used
in mobile browsers.
And then finally, and this
hasn't actually been mentioned
I believe yet today,
we support WebGL.
WebGL is, I believe in all
the latest builds of all
the modern browsers.
It's defintely a chromium
which I have running here.
WebGL is basically an
infrastructure taking advantage
of a much higher performance
graphics libraries
that are available.
As I said most of the modern
browsers and is available
on all modern machines.
That's very exciting.
And I will say just to
reiterate this point, the
Google Maps API version 3 which
supports WebGL, HTML five, HTML
4, doesn't require you to make
any decisions about
what to support.
We will figure all of
that out for you.
We'll detect what the browser
is doing, what it's capable
of, and then display
the appropriate Street
View at that point.
Let me do a quick demo of this.
This is a demo that I'm going
to come back to when I talk
about geo location that
actually shows you some of the
perils of geo location.
The idea here is that they auto
detected my location which you
can probably tell is not
actually where I am.
I'll talk to you a bit more
about that when I talk to
you about geo location.
Chad can probably tell you of
any travails he has with that.
I just wanted to show you
street view and what
it looks like here.
And I'm gonna just
drop this in here.
This is street view in Web geo.
You can see it's very highly
performanced and we actually
have one of the engineers in
the audience, Mark, here who
created this implementation and
can tell you a lot more about
it and I believe will in one
of his later presentations.
So anyway, that's very exciting
but it's a lot more exciting to
think about it in terms of what
does it look like on
a mobile device?
I'm about to show you something
that we haven't talked to
you a lot about in previous
talks on mobile devices.
I'm gonna show you what this
looks like on the iPad.
Let's see if the iPad does
a little bit better job of
picking up the location.
00:14:44,96 --> 00:14:44,758
It does.
You'll see here it actually
manages to find us in San
Francisco, which is great.
Here I am going to drill down a
little bit into San Francisco
right around where we're
located and show you
what this looks like.
We'll see if up here in the
upper left corner the street
view control is there.
I'm gonna drop it in.
It's going to take a moment.
I think you are probably all
aware of the Wi-Fi network
having been under considerable
amount of stress today.
This is street view in a
browser on a mobile device.
This is on the iPad.
I'm very excited to be able
to show this to you today.
I actually meant to do
something today which was to
pre-cache the imagery for
this location and I didn't.
I don't know if you saw
how fast that came up.
Oh, I managed to turn
the whole iPad.
That's one of the things you
have to prepare when you're
00:16:01,618 --> 00:16:01,2
doing these presentations.
So you can see here, it's
moving a little bit more slowly
than it would on the Web
because this is doing HTML
floor street view instead of
Web GL which is, I believe
our most performant version.
And I can show you a similar
thing on the Android device but
I think I'm moving a little bit
behind where I wanted to be.
It's actually very easy to set
up the code to add the street
view control your map.
It's actually just this
first line here, this
first couple of lines.
Now I'm over to the right.
You see map dot set option and
Street View control true.
Or you can do it when
you create the map,
you add that in.
That's it, that adds
Street View to your map.
If you want, you can do quite a
bit more and I don't have time
to get into the full details
of what the capabilities are.
You can also create in
separate panorama.
So you see here I create
a separate panorama and
then set it's position.
And then of course if I
wanna actually do it
entirely without a
map.
That's what the
code looks like.
I wanted to talk to you about
some of the different options
-- as I mentioned earlier --
for coding with Google Maps
API on a mobile device.
So the first one here is
browser based maps and the
advantage here is that a
browser gives you full
JavaScript support.
It lets you access some of the
features that are on the phone
particularly around geo
location and sometimes on
phones you'll actually get
access to local storage
and that sort of thing.
You can write your map once.
So this is the end
point of the talk.
You can probably go home now
and you'll have learned the
major point here which is
using the JavaScript browser
based map, that's what we
consider the best answer.
It allows for rapid
development.
You create the web page on your
server and then it gets loaded.
There's no changes that need to
happen to the application that
loads it because it's entirely
happening within a browser.
The next time somebody visits
the site, they get the most
recent version of your page.
You don't have to submit your
applications to the out the
App store and get it approved
or the Android Marketplace.
You don't have to get any
sort of approvals there.
You don't have to make your
users download the application.
On the other hand, one of the
disadvantages is, you don't get
to the discoverability that you
would otherwise have within the
App store or the Marketplace.
So on the flip side you have
the native API's -- sorry --.
So you've got Map Kit and Map
View on the iPhone and Andorid.
These are closely, tightly
integrated with the individual
phones and if you're only
developing for an individual
device, if you're only writing
an iPhone application or only
writing an Android application,
it's a pretty decent choice.
You don't get as many of the
features as you do in the
JavaScript API but if you just
want code in Objective C, if
you just wanna code in Java,
that's one of your options.
You have a little bit better
performance as well.
Because it's more tightly
integrated with the operating
system and not running in
a browser, there are some
better performance points.
On the flip side, the
developments a little bit
harder and you can't
repurpose code that
you did in JavaScript.
You can't repurpose that
for another platform.
So as I mentioned you can
embed a browser within
your applications.
That would be with web
view on Android or UI
web view on the iPhone.
That gives you access to
additional features to the
phone that might not be
available through the browser
that you can then push into
the browser through some
JavaScript interface.
It allows you to keep doing the
rapid development of the map
piece of it but also to take
advantage of some of the
advantages of iPhone and
Android development.
On the flip side of that you
still have to go through your
App store departments and you
also have to then develop for
each individual platform.
Of course a strategy could
involve both doing hybrid
applications and having a plain
web site that people could
discover in other ways as well.
Finally I want to mention
the Static Maps API.
The Static Maps which is
basically an image server.
It'll send out to any
browser, an image of a map.
It's actually now quite
customizable and very
highly performant.
The image of the map sends it
out and you just put it in the
image tag in your
web application.
You don't need to support
JavaScript in the browser
on the platform.
So it can be used on a much
wider variety of platforms but
you don't get any of the modern
features of a modern Maps API.
So no map slippiness,
it's just an image.
And any of the other
features, you don't get
any dynamism in that.
I'm a little concerned about my
time so I just want to talk to
you about some of the different
user interface considerations
that you might run into.
Actually before I do that, I
want to talk to you about just
some of the different platforms
that you might run into.
Think about this, screen
size is a pretty big deal.
So when you're talking about
a desktop or laptop, screen
size is not as much of a big
deal for a webpage right?
If your map is twenty five
inches across versus fifteen
inches across, it's
still a pretty big map.
You've still got a lot
of details on there.
If you're developing for an
iPhone or an Android device, an
iPad, which is somewhere in
between, or a desktop browser
or -- this is my Static Maps
API image there -- those
are all very different.
I want you to think about that
when you're thinking about the
development and what the
implications of that are.
Go back to this slide.
And just some of the things
that you might think
about are screen size.
When you're creating your map,
make your divs flexible.
Don't set absolute pixel
boundaries on them unless you
know exactly the platform that
it's being displayed on cause
you won't necessarily know
the size of your screen.
Vary the chorme, the stuff
that goes around it by the
browser that's accessing it.
Just put in some dynamic
stylesheets If you know that
it's being loaded on a mobile
device, then you know that
you don't necessarily want
to put chrome around it.
You might wanna put a tab
instead so that somebody can
get to session information
at Google IO on a separate
tab from the actual map.
But if you're displaying it in
a browser that's sitting on a
desktop or a laptop, you might
want to put a whole bunch more
stuff around it so that people
can get access to
that information.
And I just mentioned
session information at IO.
I wanted to show you one of the
Apps that you might have seen.
This is the Google IO map.
How many of you downloaded
the Google IO application
on your Android device?
This is the map that
shows up in that.
It's the exact same map.
It shifts the user interface.
We'll see here as
I'm moving around.
When I practiced this
before I didn't have the
cord plugged into it.
Which is why I've had the
That's another danger in
creating for mobile devices.
So you'll see here I didn't
actually go through -- cause I
wanted to show you what the
performance actually looks like
-- I didn't go through and
pre-cache these tiles either.
So that's actually fairly high
performance and including by
the way, some of these tiles
are our custom tiles, where
you see the lunch cafe's
and that sort of thing.
That's custom tiles that
were created specifically
for this application.
So if you have an Android,
you can download this and
put this on your phone.
The Google IO application.
If you don't, ask
somebody who does.
So you can see there that's
a nice hybrid application.
So keep in mind too that
people are going to have
to do touch events.
Which may impact what you
put in your user interface.
People are gonna have to
actually physically touch
things in order to
get them to open up.
So if you want to have a map
marker there, you're gonna have
to figure out what is the size
on the screen but also and make
sure that things are accessible
and easily touchable by
somebody particularly like me
who was has very large fingers.
And also think about, if you're
doing a native or hybrid
application, you get some of
the native look and feel
of the application.
Now there are some projects out
there to try and help you get
that native look and feel
within a browser application.
So IUI is one example of that.
That's something that you might
want to have -- its always a
trade off -- if you're masking
your application as if it were
in a native application.
That kind of tricks your users
into thinking that it is a
native application even
if its in a browser.
On the other hand, maybe
that's what you want.
Maybe not necessiarly tricking
your users but just presenting
them with a fairly
consistent user interface.
So that's one of the
things that you might
want to consider.
So i'm gonna spend a few
more minutes talking
about geo location.
Now geo location is the process
of getting a device to
tell you where you are.
Now this is one of the places
where these devices, these
mobile devices actually have
something up the on the desktop
and the laptop environment
which is that these things
actually know where they are.
They actually know a fair
amount about were they are.
They know where they are.
They know often what their
angle is, lots of information
about how you're
holding the device.
They also can figure
out where you've been.
So these are some things that
you want to have access to and
it's often what drives people
towards native applications
or hybrid applications.
They want to be able to
capture control of that.
The latest versions of both the
Android and iPhone SDK is,
the broswers support a
HTML 5 geo location.
HTML 5 geo location is
basically, the device tells the
browser, this is where I am.
The browser doesn't necessarily
know exactly where it is.
It uses the device to give it
some clues as to where it is.
So then the device figures
out how to do that.
It can send some options to it.
You can send some
refinements to that.
I'm gonna walk you through
a few of the things but I
encourage you to check
out the spec on it.
And also after the session, up
in the hacker alcove, we're
going to be doing a quick code
lab in the hacker alcove.
If you want to sit down with
some people from geo, including
myself, to help you out with
that, to get started using geo
location and working with
street view on the device,
follow me after this session.
As I said, there's HTML 5 geo
location and then for things
that can't access that, there's
also IP based geo location.
Now you can see where
that might fail.
I displayed something earlier
which showed us -- let me see
if i can pull that up again
-- in Rancho Cucamonga.
I'm gonna admit right now
that I'm not actually
sure where that is.
I think it's in southern
California based on --
sorry -- so it's in LA.
So you can see the danger.
You can also see that different
browsers will provide you
with different methods of
finding your geo location.
And I pull up Firefox because
Firefox also provides generally
something better and also
because I hadn't gone to
this page before here.
You'll see here it gives
you an actual option.
First time you visit a page,
it'll ask you, do you want to
share your location with this?
All the browsers
will do this now.
This is a privacy mechanism
but its something that
you need to anticipate.
If somebody doesn't want to
share their location with
you, then code around that.
What is it that you set?
What's your default?
That's really up to you.
So here I'm gonna click on
share location and Firefox also
places me in Rancho Cucamonga.
Oh that's interesting.
So earlier it placed me right
in San Francisco but now it's
was placing me in
Rancho Cucamonga.
It probably means that they're
getting it the same way.
Now the different ways they get
it are the different browsers
will have services that are
sort from the back and
they'll do an IP look up.
That's sort of the coarsest,
worst way to determine
your location.
They'll look at the IP
address of the request
then return something.
And then another way is to look
at the local Wi-Fi networks try
and make guesses as
to where you are.
Apparently there are similarly
named Wi-Fi netwoeks
around here.
I am going a little over
time so I am gonna try
and power through this.
I just wanna show you
some of the code.
This is how simple it is to
get HTML 5 geo location.
This was one line here:
navigator dot geo locatoin
dot get current position.
And then you pass it a
function that it then
calls when it has it.
That would be like show map,
which would do something.
There is however a lot more
functions in geo location.
So you can do things like
watch the position.
Just keep coming back and
changing the position
when it changes.
You can look at the
age of the position.
So if the device provides you
with some of the age there,
you can get directly the
time stamp, when somebody
was at that location.
And finally the accuracy.
Now you may have seen, in this
one, it makes a guess as to the
accuracy and then what I did
was I took advantage of
JavaScript's new circle overlay
to just draw a circle
around it based on the
accuracy in meters.
So what it says is somewhere
within this radius,
this is where you are.
Now of course this is not
accurate but generally,
particularly if you have GPS
based access on the phone,
it'll be within a fairly, on a
mobile device particularly,
within a fairly narrow area,
within a few blocks usually.
And sometimes very
tight around that.
So I recommend when you're
doing this kind of application,
to take advantage of the
accuracy measure and actually
display that to the developer,
I'm sorry, to the user, cause
that will give them some
indication of how accurate
your positions is.
If you're operating on a
browser, as you see here, some
the browsers do support HTML
5 geo locations but some
of them like IE do not.
Some of the older
browsers do not.
We also have a client location
which is actually part
of the AJAX API's.
What I recommend doing is, see
if you have HTML 5 geo location
and if not, fall back
to something using
client location.
There's a lot more things
in HTML 5 I don't
have time to go over.
But basically look for more
HTML 5 support in applications.
And I don't have time for this
last demo so I'm just going to
go ahead and switch
over to Chad.
So Chad.
CHAD KILLINGSWORTH: So I get
the joy of showing you an
acutal use case of what it
takes to make a version 3 map
actually function on mobile
devices in the real
world scenario.
I work at a university
and we're using it
for our campus map.
We have, at the University, as
far as mapping is concerned,
two distinct groups
of audiences.
Our internal audiences would
be faculty, staff, and
our enrolled students.
And they have strongly told us
that they prefer an application
to run on the device.
They don't want a bookmark,
they want an actual
application.
However, at the same time, I
have visitors and guests to
campus who may be coming to
take a tour, coming to a
sporting event, coming to a
theatrical performance; they're
going to show up at the parking
lot and open the map in the
browser and there's nothing I
can do to change that behavior.
So I have two
distinct use cases.
This is the scenario where the
hybrid application comes in
really well especially
considering that I don't have
hundreds of developers.
I only have the resources to
maintain one map application.
So the hybrid application
lets me kind of do both.
The first thing you got to do
is, I have to migrate my
version 2 map to version 3.
There was an entire session
about this, but some quick high
points: all my data sets are
identical between -- I
still have a functioning
version 2 of the map.
If you visit it in your browser
you're gonna see the version 2
-- the same jason data, the
same search index, the same KML
layers all work between both,
no modifications needed.
Early on there was some
problems with the version 3 in
that, a lot of the features
were write your own.
That's not really a
problem anymore.
In fact it's really easy
if you using KML layers.
The probably biggest
development challenge is the
small screen and the user
interface and making
it touch based.
So, with that in mind, let's
look at the hybrid application.
Now I had some pretty big
concerns about doing this:
the first being performance.
When it was loaded in a
browser, I knew my users would
give me some slack with the
performance because it's a web
browswer and you just
kind of expect this.
But I was really concerned
about when it was an
application because then
they're going to be directly
comparing it to the Native maps
application on the phone.
So if my hybrid application is
slow, there can be a pretty
low tolerance for that.
That one, it turns out, is
pretty easy to work around, as
long as you take some thought
and go through all
the optimizations.
We'll talk about a few of
them here in just a second.
The performance within the
browser is pretty good;
especially for return visitors
when you do some of the HTML 5
local storage and caching
it works pretty well.
The last one is purely
psychological and that is
a developer, this method
feels like cheating.
I had to get over the idea that
my native application is really
just a glorified bookmark.
However, I put the graph on
here to show you -- let me see
if I can use both the bottom
button -- the blue line is
the segment, that's all the
traffic to my mobile map.
The green line at the bottom,
that's where someone opens it
in their web browser and the
orange line is usage from
within the application.
So you can see that my users
don't really care that
is just a bookmark.
They much prefer the
actual application.
When I'm beginning to see
this type of data, that
psychological barrier
just kind of goes away.
If users like it like this and
are using it like this, then
that's definitely
the way to go.
Let me show you now kind of
what this looks like on
a few different devices.
The icon on the left is
the actual application.
This is the bookmark saved
to their home screen.
So in this case, the iPhone
shows a splash image and
will block showing you the
map until the load event
in the window occurs.
So I'm not going to see as
much feedback while it
loads and we'll see how
the wireless network does.
And it's gonna ask me if I
wanna use my current location.
In this case you can
notice the interface.
Now, I can turn on
different layers.
Let's see if any shuttles are
actually running on the campus
right now -- yup I've
got 2 routes running.
I can look at the parking lots.
I can actually search for a
building, although I'm gonna
show you that on the iPad cause
it's a little easier to type.
Let's look at the same thing
on an Android device.
In this case I'm gonna actually
show you the application; it
is identical to the iPhone.
Here I had it preloaded
because Android remembers.
So it's already got my layers
up and my buses are running.
And also one other thing,
I have even more layers.
We can turn on the bike routes.
That's the one complaint I have
is my controls are too small.
So now I can see not only the
bike layers, but I can see
the bike racks on campus.
And when I get to the edge
on my campus bike map, it
automatically goes to the
Google Maps bikeways layer.
And finally on the iPad.
And in this case I want to
search for an actual location
and I'm gonna use the building
code that would show up
in our class schedule.
I don't know where that
building is and there it is.
And last but not least, let's
find out where we are.
And since I'm nowhere close
to my map, it actually
puts us in San Francisco.
That gives you some idea
of how the geo location
works with this.
In order to make this work well
for users though, I have spent
a considerable amount of
time on optimizations.
In fact, it seems like every
other week I'm finding a
new thing to do or to try.
Here's some of the top
ones that I found that
make the most impact.
The first one was, use KML
layers for complicated data.
Complicated does not take much.
Before KML layers, a
typical use case would
be to open the map.
There would be a tile layer,
about 6 relatively simple
polylines, showing the
bus routes and maybe 30
markers on the screen.
Even on some of the fastest
Android devices, with that
data, there's a noticeable
delay when panning.
Loading wan't great, drawing,
SPG seems particular slow with
the p But with KML layers,
just really snappy.
I essentially had the overhead
of a single tile layer.
The second one is to
compress your JavaScript.
My JavaScript, not the maps
API, but my JavaScript, is
around 36K -- I've cut a lot
out of it -- uncompressed.
With using closure compiler and
the advanced optimizations mode
closure and compiler, I can
get it down to about 13K.
If you're interested in using
closure compiler there's
already a extern file available
for the version 3 Maps API.
It was up to date as of Sunday;
obviously the announcements
this week aren't there yet.
Another optimization which
really has nothing to do with
speed, more to show users
progress, is you can delay
loading so you're not
blocking script tags.
And mobile browsers still block
page rendering so, you can
kind of delay that and show
some progressive loading.
For instance, I'm loading the
Maps API boot loader code at
dynamically adding the script
tag at the DOM content
loaded event.
And then I dynamically add my
script tag when the map's
tiles loaded event occurs.
So the user sees more and more
features coming into the map.
It's not any faster overall
time but they see more progress
and it gives a better
user experience.
And then kind of the last
one is, use and love
Google page speed.
It has a whole lot of
optimizations it'll tell you.
Even some of the smallest
changes can make a significant
difference on your
slower devices.
One of the slowest and
most frustrating is the
iPhone 3G, not the 3GS.
Anything you can do to
speed that up is well
worth the effort.
Also, if you're interested in
how any of this is working, my
JavaScript search code
is compressed with
closure complier.
There's a comment at the top of
the file to a blog post that
lists out all the uncompressed
source that you can go take a
look at and see any of it.
MANO MARKS: Thank you John.
So I want to mention this,
we're putting this into pretty
much every slide deck.
If you wanna tone this
out, that's fine.
Basically, we have a developer
qualification program and that
program is designed to
basically, similar to
certification programs, just to
identify developers who are
accomplished and who contribute
a lot to the developer
community and then allow
them to have ways to be
easily discoverable.
So if you want to find out more
about it, we're launching the
developer qualification for V3.
So I urge you take a look at
that, and get qualified.
So, we're now going to switch
over to looking at questions
that anybody might have.
So I'm gonna switch this over
to -- it's number two right,
no, number one -- but also if
you have any questions feel
to come up to one of these
microphones here and ask us any
problems you've have with
developing for mobile devices.
Please let us know.
So you wanna come up Chad, and
we'll answer any questions.
So what's the deal
with the censor flag?
That's a really good question.
Basically the licensing terms
that we have with a lot of our
data providers requires us to
indicate whether or not we're
using a sensor or somebody is
using a sensor to detect
a location when they're
displaying something on a map.
So in this case, if you're
using geo locations -- which I
probably should have mentioned
earlier -- you need
to set this to true.
Otherwise set it to false if
you're not using a sensor to
detect location and then
display it on the map.
A lot of people think that,
that actually provides you with
access to the location but
setting that there is just
about when you're
loading the map.
Let's take this question here.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering with
hybrid applications, if either
of you could comment, how hard
is it to get data into the
Andorid web view and back out?
MANO MARKS: From your device?
AUDIENCE: Yeah
MANO MARKS: It's very easy.
You can expose a JavaScript
interface to any of the native
services and to data stores.
You just basically write, --
I'm just thinking in terms of
Android -- just write an
additional function in
and then expose it as a
JavaScript interface.
CHAD KILLINGSWORTH: There's
actually an article on the
version 3 site that talks about
developing a hybrid application
and it's not very long but it
shows you the full process to
get a working map application.
MANO MARKS: Can maps licensing
be simplified so that you
can buy a license online?
Is Dan Chu in the audience?
So, there are enterprise
people here who you can
talk to about that.
We're aware that the process of
getting licensing for Google
Maps API premiere is not easy
and also presents some
unique challenges for
mobile developers.
So try and see Dan Chu here,
he's actually the PM for
Goggle Maps API premiere.
Or talk to somebody else about
that afterwards but yeah,
I would love to see that.
In the browser based API why
does pinch to zoom work
on the iPhone browser
and not on Android.
That's a problem that I
believe that were working on.
Mark, do you want to
comment on that.
Mark, one of the core
developers for Maps API.
MARK: For pinch to zoom we
require special browser
JavaScript events which on the
iPhone are the gesture events
and the touch events
with multiple touch.
Those events are not currently
exposed by other browsers such
as Android or the other
mobile platforms.
So we limit it for the moment,
to only support pinch to zoom
on the iPhone because it's the
only platform where we
receive those events.
So even on Android devices that
have pinch to zoom behavior, so
that you can scale your browser
and see characters bigger,
at the JavaScript level we
don't receive those events.
I believe it's coming up.
I haven't seen, for the moment,
any other browsers, other
than the iPhone, that
expose those events.
CHAD KILLINGSWORTH: There's
actually an issue in the issue
tracker for the Maps API V 3
about that, that you can follow
to keep up to date about
where that issue stands.
MARK: Obviously, as soon as we
can see those events we just
turn on the flag and start
processing them, so
we're ready for it.
MANO MARKS: So this is one of
the advantages actually of
using the JavaScript Maps
API which is that we do all
that kind of work for you.
So when there's a change to
browsers or when we can add new
features to it, we can add them
to them and it'll just happen
without you having to make
changes to how you
implement the API.
CHAD KILLINGSWORTH: Another
real world example of that type
of update is last week when KML
layers became available
in version 3.
I was able to roll out the
update to where my map now uses
full KML layers without any
change to the hybrid
application whatsoever
because it's just using the
JavaScript in a browser.
MANO MARKS: Can you provide
images or video say, via street
view, of the inside of a
building once located by GPS?
Will the API let me report
where I am in the building?
Currently the street view API
does not allow you to move
inside panorama's that aren't
in the API, aren't already in
street view -- so sorry, Mark?
oh we do now -- we do
allow you to do that.
I apologize, I
missed that part.
So yes, you can
you can do that.
CHAD KILLINGSWORTH: One note is
though, that when you're in a
building, the geo location
from even mobile devices
becomes less accurate.
MANO MARKS: One might even
say particularly, from
mobile devices, becomes
far less accurate.
MARK: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
MANO MARKS: Mark is saying,
just to clarify the issue, we
don't provide, at this point,
we don't provide view of the
insides of buildings but if you
create your own, you can create
those panoramas yourself.
And they are in the
documentation and Tom, who
wrote the documentation, is
actually sitting right
here in the audience.
I thought I'd call him out
cause he's giving a talk
later today, right on --
TOM: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
MANO MARKS: -- Yeah,
on maps data, yeah.
TOM: [INAUDIBLE].
MANO MARKS: And the reference
went live today right,
for street view?
In about twenty minutes?
So in about twenty minutes
the reference will be
live for street view.
OK did any additional
questions get added in?
Any more questions?
We got about five minutes.
What I actually wanted to do
with the demo is to show
you a little bit about
the code on this one.
So let me just do some view
on it, view source rather.
Walk you through a little bit.
So this is on the geo location
demo that I was using earlier.
Let me just get used to a
MAC here, for a moment.
I wanted to just show you here.
You'll see the function do geo
location, which basically says
if there is navigator dot geo
location, then get the
current position.
You'll see here it has 2 call
backs: position success
and position error.
Position error returns an error
message if it's not able to
determine something even though
it has the geo location,
otherwise, produce a
particular error.
More importantly, though
here, is position success.
I should stay on
one screen here.
So basically here you just do,
-- move the cursor out of the
way -- it gives you position
object which gives
you access to cords.
And then you set a lat-long.
Then I took the accuracy here,
set the center, created at the
new lat-long object, set
the zoom level to 12.
I created a marker and then
created a circle which had a
radius of the accuracy
of the measurement.
That's really all it took
to do that geo location.
Another thing I want to note
here is --I set -- here's the
code for using the default UI.
You don't actually
have to do this but I
wanted to call it out.
I did not disable the
default user interface.
I did allow for the
street view control.
What that means then is, on
this here, because this is
displaying as a slightly
smaller map, we'll see
it's displaying the
smaller controls.
If I were at a greater
resolution, it would
display a larger control.
Let me see if I expand
this if I can get it to.
Oh I think it's because
I had zoomed out.
So you see here when I get it
in a slightly larger one,
the controls over here, on
the left hand portion of
the screen they change.
And here's the peg man that
gets added for the street
view control there.
It's very simple to set up
a map that takes account
of geo location.
And then also, automatically
changes depending on the
screen size, the size of
the actual map itself.
The question is, can you
programatically change the
direction the street view is
pointing and make it move,
and the answer is yes.
In about 19 minutes,
check the documentation
for how to do that.
You have quite a bit of control
and, as noted in earlier
sessions, if you put a marker
on a map, it will show up
in the panorama as well.
So you have this nice sort
of cross experience there.
Markers don't just disappear
when you move into some other
field, which is a nice
change there as well.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you have, in the
browser, set up tabs so that
when you have it on the mobile
they are as tabs, kind
of has an interface?
Or its gonna be only the map
and you're gonna have the
same icons fit for the --
MANO MARKS: I'm sorry,
I'm not following you.
AUDIENCE: -- so when
you program and you
do it like this.
When you look at it on iPhone
or Android, it's going to be
just the map, there's
no tabulation?
It doesn't give another
user interface.
MANO MARKS: You can.
So basically you do it
in JavaScript, you can
detect browser size.
You can also look at user
agents and get some idea of
what the sizes that you're
looking for and then
dynamically change your style
sheets to switch over to say a
tabbed interface or some other
interface that might give you
give you a different experience
based on the actual size.
AUDIENCE: And that would become
active depending on the
device you're looking at?
MANO MARKS: Yeah, you would
develop that based on your
user interface design.
That's independent
of the Maps API.
That's all the time
that we have.
If you have any questions,
feel free to ask Chad or I.
I'm also going to be sort
of sliding up towards
the hacker alcove which
is the next session.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]: